alors en ce qui concerne les accès à la
préfecture de police
j'ai pu accéder de mémoire cinq fois la
préfecture de police les deux premières
c'était pendant la campagne
présidentielle
donc j'étais pas en fonction à l'elysée
et c'était concernant une me semble de
mémoire le grand meeting qui avait eu à
porte de versailles et la deuxième phase
était la phase de préparation
du louvre de la soirée victorieuse donc
je venais en tant que représentant de
l'équipe de campagne et j'y suis allée
accompagné de jean marie cherrier qui
était le directeur de campagne
et donc quand vous arrivez vous
présenter avec une pièce d'identité et
un policier qui vient vous chercher où
une dame un agent administratif qui vous
emmène jusqu'à la salle de réunion vous
y attendez le préfet il ya un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont des
représentants de la presse de la
préfecture de police le directeur de
leur public de la circulation le
directeur le dspe ap la directrice du
renseignement et vous expliquer un peu
combien de personnes vous allez recevoir
etc ça c'était à deux reprises pendant
la campagne présidentielle les trois
autres fois où je suis allé à la
préfecture de police à deux reprises
c'était pour la préparation du sommet
qui s'appelle le one planet summit qui
s'est tenu l'année dernière et donc il y
avait c'était un dispositif assez lourd
parce qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
chefs d'état et de gouvernement dont un
certain nombre de questions abordées
avec eux j'y suis allée accompagner
du général de farina en tant que
représentant de la chefferie de cabinet
et je suis arrivé en voiture j'ai
présenté ma pièce d'identité on m'a fait
me garer sur le stationnement réservées
aux invités et j'ai été accompagné par
un agent administratif jusqu'à la salle
les deux autres fois
c'est donc les deux jeunes a cédé deux
fois pour la réunion du one planet
schmitt la dernière fois j'y suis allé
dans les faits qu'on ne peut pas parler
aujourd'hui
accompagné par un policier
officiellement un policier de la
préfecture de police qui m'a accompagné
dans la salle au même titre que les
collaborateurs de mise aux intérieurs
ils sont allés accompagnés par des
policiers moi je suis content des
collaborateurs du président la
république en fonction voilà